very interesting new study about
religious groups in the United States
that I want to discuss with you the
fastest growing religious group in the
country is no religion in other words
people who don't associate with any
particular religion and this is not a
new trend this is actually something
that we've been seeing for a while every
time pew the Pew Religion Center does
this report on I believe it's a yearly
basis and we're actually seeing the
increased number of people not
affiliated with religion have real
measurable impact so churches are
closing all around the country or are
having to merge communities that used to
have six churches if you can imagine it
in some cases are merging and combining
and end up sometimes with only two or
three churches we're seeing more
political candidates than ever not
professing a religion many at the local
level more at the state level notably
Kyrsten Sinema who recently has taken
over victory of her Senate seat from
Arizona over Republican martha mcsalley
the first senator to not profess a
religion so we're seeing this more and
more and the Pew Research Center as I
mentioned again has their study on this
issue out and not surprisingly when we
break these results down by age the
younger you are the more likely you are
to select none as your religion if
looking at the results here as we are
together you'll notice that the Silent
Generation born between 28 and 45 has
nearly 90 percent of its constituents
professing a religion whereas baby
boomers and more so Generation X and
more so older Millennials and even more
so younger Millennials at 36 percent
profess that they are not affiliated
with any religion when people are
interviewed about having left typically
its their Christian Church merely from a
from a numbers perspective most people
in the u.s. at least nominally identify
as Christian when they identify with a
religion people are asked well why did
you leave
sometimes they
about you know the teachings don't
relate to real life I don't feel like
there's any connection between the
teachings and and my actual life or the
rituals don't mean anything to me or I
actually am just bored or uninterested
in the rituals there's a lot of that but
I actually have a more sort of
evolutionary perspective on the fading
of religion Pat for me it's sort of like
a survival of the fittest or natural
selection kind of approach to the fading
of religion in the United States of
America historically survival has been
very accurately predicted by the ability
of individuals and groups to cooperate
if this sin can include in small numbers
this can also include in large numbers
and one of the big distinguishing
factors between Homo sapiens and earlier
humans and Homo sapiens and other
species is that Homo sapiens can
cooperate in very large numbers in
flexible ways so to give you counter
examples chimpanzees can cooperate
flexibly they can cooperate in foraging
or hunting or building shelters simple
shelters in some cases whatever but they
can only do that in small groups like
chimpanzees can't organize themselves in
a group of 500 bees are an example of a
species that can coordinate in huge
numbers beehives with thousands of bees
they can coordinate but only inflexibly
on very narrow tasks if bees all of a
sudden need to coordinate 5,000 bees to
file a tax return I mean it's a dumb
example but on something something
bigger they're not able to do it and
humans can cooperate flexibly in large
numbers years ago many many years ago
being part of a religious group
increased your chances of survival
people who help you religion increased
collaboration for in-group members we
know that that's the case and therefore
you actually had a higher chance of
survival of living long enough to have
children and pass along your genes that
is now less likely to happen you're not
as likely to suffer in 2018 as a result
of bee
unable to cooperate with mankind because
you're not part of a religious group
it's less necessary it's less
advantageous in 2018 to be part of a
religious group it's no longer an issue
of survival not to be religious if you
look even today at places where you're
less likely to survive as an atheist
there are fewer atheists the
evolutionary advantage to religious
belief still exists in some places like
look at a country Yemen is an example in
Yemen the population says that religion
is extraordinarily important to them
something like 98 99 percent of the
population says religion is
extraordinarily important in Yemen there
probably is a measurably higher chance
of dying before reproducing if you're
not religious contrast that with
someplace like Norway or Sweden some of
the least religious countries in the
world there's no real advantage to
religion in the survival sense there's
no cooperation advantage in Norway or
Sweden to being part of a church or a
religious group so we can look at this a
few different ways yes the more we learn
about how the world works the more that
science explains things about the world
the decreased need for religion is
noticed and that is a factor but there's
also this other sort of evolutionary
angle and there is one concern here Pat
which is that religion being none is
fine but if people are replacing
religion with this vague new age not
really religion but pretty horrible
ideas connected to pseudoscience that's
something I would be very careful about
you are you saying that I should return
all the jade eggs I bought from the GUP
website when a Paltrow's website yeah no
more vaginal steaming Pat we've got to
stop that it's extraordinarily dangerous
and you need to tell everybody in your
family who's doing it that they need to
stop right away and we're kind of
kidding but there are a lot of really
bad ideas right now under the umbrella
not of organized religious belief but
more sort of agnostic teachings and and
anti-vaccine sentiment the pseudoscience
stuff that
bringing up that's based on or
advertised on Gwyneth Paltrow's website
goop the type of garbage that dr. oz
promotes it's really important to keep
an eye on that but the trend with
organized religion is very clear it's
dwindling in the United States and the
biggest upside for me like you know we
you can say David we should care about
people believing things without evidence
no matter whether they're doing it
privately or publicly or both fine we
can argue it's not good for people to
literally believe that if you eat shrimp
you're going to hell or whatever right I
mean whatever the teachings are the
biggest upside for me though is in the
end if people believe whatever they
believe privately if it doesn't impact
what they want to have happen in the
public sphere if they are okay with
total separation of church and state I
don't really care what they believe
privately although I might disagree with
it
the upside for me of more people in the
United States
professing none as their religion is
that it should allow it to be easier for
our elected officials to be much more
clear much more direct much more
black-and-white on the issue of
secularism meaning a total separation of
church and state and that that's a good
thing because that's actually a
principle the country was founded on and
now here's my question to you or my
proposal to you if you're hearing me
tell this story of people moving away
from religion in the United States and
you think it's bad you think it would be
better for people in the United States
to remain more religious or to move back
towards religion please get in touch
with me and let me know why why is it
bad that people are moving away from
religion in the United States I want to
hear from you we will also ask for
thoughts on this via our Instagram
account instagram.com slash david pakman
show make sure you're following us there
and also follow me on instagram at david
pakman you can find behind the scenes
pictures of the new studio and much more
we will take a quick break
what a program we have for you today